welcome to alpha the city of a thousand
planet after centuries of peace and
prosperity an unknown force ought to
destroy all we have created we need the
two of you to be the guardians of our
future
[Music]
52:13 welcome to us
[Music]
the city is under attack
how destiny is in your hands
[Music]
malaria mom witty pg-13 this mission is
a simple in and out
agent valerian he'll be running solo I
only work with my partner hi
we're a team
you're running nearly 20 minutes late
there well time flies when you're having
fun
[Music]
welcome to alpha
the city of a thousand planets where for
hundreds of years every species has
shared their knowledge and their
intelligence with each other it's
paradise
[Music]
after centuries of peace and prosperity
an unknown force wants to destroy all we
have created agents valerian and Laura
lein you have less than 10 hours to find
the threat and eliminate it
phone universes after us we need the two
of you to be the guardians of our future
you
you sure you thought you'd do it
valerian drops
how much time one
[Music]
not destiny is in your hands
I taught him how to do that
you
you